- [Voiceover] We're told
that each square below
represents one whole.
So this square is a whole,
this is another whole,
so together that's two.
And then we have
something less than whole.
And they say what decimal is
represented by the shaded area?
So it's going to be
two and then something.
So it's going to be two point something.
And let's think about
what we have over here.
This is one whole, two wholes.
And then over here, we've taken a whole
and we've divided it into one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten equal sections.
So we've divided it into tenths.
Each of these bars is equal to a tenth
and we have seven of them shaded in.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
So this right over here is seven tenths.
So this is going to be one, two,
and seven tenths.
So, if we wanted to
write it as mixed number
we'd write it as two and seven tenths,
but they say what decimal is represented
by the shaded area?
So instead of writing
two and seven tenths,
we could write 2.7.
Because the space immediately to the right
of the decimal points,
that's the tenths place.
So we have two ones, two
wholes right over here.
And then we have seven tenths,
this is the tenths place.
And we could check out answer.
We got it right.
Let's do another one of these.
So the same thing.
What decimal is represented
by the shaded area?
So we have three wholes,
and then this whole is
divided into tenths,
now it's divided into these vertical bars.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten
vertical bars.
They're equal, so they're
divided into tenths,
and we've shaded in five of them.
So this one over here is five tenths.
So it is three wholes and five tenths.
So it's going to be three wholes
and in the tenths place we would put five.
3.5, three wholes and five tenths.
We can check our answer.
Got it right.
Let's do a few more of these.
What decimal is being
represented by the shaded area?
So over here, let's see,
I have a hundred squares.
You see I have 10 columns
and each of them has 10 squares in it,
so 10 times 10 is 100.
So I have 100 squares here, equal squares,
so I've divided it into hundredths,
and I've shaded in one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine of the hundredths.
Hundredths.
So how do I represent that?
So zero, that's the ones place.
That's the tenths place.
And now I'm in the hundredths place.
And so we have nine of
the hundredths shaded in.
So this right over here
would be nine hundredths,
which is exactly what we have there.
Alright, let's do,
let's do one more of these.
Alright, well it's the same thing.
We have two of the hundredths filled in.
So I'll write zero point,
if I did that that would be two tenths.
That's not what we have filled in.
We have two hundredths.
Hundredths filled in.
So this is 0.02 and we're done.